advice on just how to navigate the
holiday shopping season is charisse
jones she's an economic economic
opportunity reporter for usa today good
morning cherise good morning well
millions are expected out there what are
the hottest items this year i mean it's
always the xboxes the nintendos all of
those electronic items the smartphones
the personal computers but it's going to
be a little bit harder to get them this
year because the semiconductor chip
which is like the key component and all
those gadgets and gizmos is in short
supply so you might have to you know
rearrange your your shopping plans this
year how can they work around that
problem that's the supply chain issue
you know definitely get out to the sales
today cyber monday's coming up there
might be some items that are available
you might be able to get a good discount
but also think about going low-tech
this holiday season right i mean if you
can't yeah an actual book
a baseball or a board game or a puzzle i
was watching tv the other day and i saw
a play-doh commercial right and when i
was little i loved play-doh so be
creative and not be dependent on the
technology as much is there a better way
you know you think online especially
with covid so many of us that's all we
did we couldn't go into stores but is it
better online or going into the brick
and mortar stores now i mean you can do
either i mean obviously they're taking
safety precautions they're not as
crowded they're trying to make sure that
not as many people come in and you can
get the same deals both online and in
stores so it's just whatever you're
comfortable with so are there shortcuts
that people can take to make sure their
stuff gets
on time
exactly well you can go online and look
at the website and see if there's a
local store that has the item and then
if it's in stock get out there get to
that store and buy it so you avoid
waiting on pins and needles for it to
get there and paying those shipping
costs there's also a site called hot
stock dot io you can go right here
and they really keep track of the hard
to find items so you can get email
alerts to find out when it's going to be
in stock a lot of stores are doing that
as well and sometimes get away from the
merchandise right do an experience you
know get you know tickets to a concert
for my friend right or things we haven't
been able to do when you're right
to a ballgame or go to a museum get some
passes for that you know so those are
some alternatives to kind of getting all
that stuff if you can't find everything
you want what have you like ordered
something and it's on back order i mean
is there anything to do
michelle's basically that this is her
life
i get it i understand i mean if it's on
back order they may give you some dates
that let you know when it's going to be
available
but sometimes the top brands sell out
first but you can still get that same
item but a different brand right like a
multi-cooker that's not an instant pot
you can find that as well so just be
open-minded well charisse jones always
has the info for us i've known her for a
long time
a lot laura she knows all my foibles
don't tell anybody we'll talk to you
afterwards
yeah and i are going to kind of see you
in your dressing room later